one of the things that is interesting
and different about pll is that the
players have equity is that right when
we went about building the pll we saw
the opportunity in our industry which
was lacrosse
and sports business and sports media we
could have just built another
mousetrap another version of what's out
there and this is like
10 and a half years into the social
media era where the power dynamic has
shifted from teams and owners to players
you've seen that come about through
athletes investing athletes taking
equity and brand partnerships and
athletes owning teams and
realizing that it doesn't have to be a
fleeting career we were like is hey if
we if we are innovators like we say we
are and if we want to disrupt sports
let's do more than just start a new
league let's change the way that maybe
professional sports at the team level
function with talent
this podcast exists because i love
talking to people and i love going deep
the purpose is to plant seeds of
inspiration we enter a space of
vulnerability and relatability and what
you realize is that we are so much more
alike than we are different to quote
ramdas we're all just walking each other
home and this show is just one step i'm
danica patrick and i'm pretty intense
today i am happy to welcome paul rabel
he is a professional lacrosse player he
is the co-founder of pll which stands
for premier lacrosse league he's an
entrepreneur and a two-time world
lacrosse champion i
was fascinated with researching paul and
knowing more about him and as i don't
know that much about lacrosse i really
get the kind of character that paul is
he's a go-getter he's open he's
transparent he's a thinker he's
intelligent he researches he's ambitious
and so it was just a really it was just
a fun conversation that took a lot of
turns that i didn't expect i mean we
even started talking about buddhism
which is definitely not something that i
thought which i did not have on my
questions for him i did not find in
research but it just shows how open he
is and he was really willing to
share his perspectives and share
what helps him feel his best what gives
him clarity with which is i think just
so helpful so we just got into some
fascinating conversations because here
he is with the premier league premier
lacrosse league starting in 2019 hitting
covet in 2020 which was obviously a
pretty big uh problem and but trying to
build it i hope that you have fun
listening to the the flow of this
conversation and find a few nuggets well
i think it's only appropriate that uh
the first thing that you said was like
oh i have a mic and i'm gonna record the
audio for you just so that you
uh because all i kept thinking with like
preparing and learning about you and
is that your
production
crew
value
drive accomplishment is so high do you
just do you have someone filming you
right now no
um
yeah no uh but we think about yeah we
think about content a lot and and i
don't i don't know if it is
my
uh just my general interest in the
creative arts and media marketing
that's part of what i oversee at the pol
that has led to this ocd in a way of
production
um or if it's just knowing the path to
growing in our case a game is through
content and so
uh as athletes
you know part of what we're
known for is our attention to detail and
that usually comes out in practice i've
found with athletes who successfully
take the next um you know step in life
in business or media or whatever it is
that they choose to do
that that practice that work ethic
translates to other things so i try to
apply that same obsessiveness that i've
had for 24 years of playing lacrosse to
other things that i do
hmm
i mean i was an athlete um
a really [ __ ] good one
um i saw that you went to indy 500 um
a couple of years ago uh
i don't i don't know if i have that same
thing like i like
i don't mind being on show and being on
but then when i come home
i hate people up in my space
you know i mean even you know
any money in the world that could afford
as many people to cook and clean and
take care of like i wouldn't want that
because i don't like people up in my biz
um meaning just in my space like i don't
care i'm an open book it's not a privacy
thing from that standpoint but just
do you ever get a little like i don't
know does it get old as i i mean
i mean i wake up in the morning and the
camera's rolling in the red light and
then you're like man i just let me get
the sleepy eyes out of my eye before i
i'm exaggerating it's probably not that
intense but there's definitely a lot of
a lot of filming happening yeah i mean
our our origins are much different right
you
and what you're able to do to not only
racing but your uh stature in the world
of
of
sports and media and business was so big
pretty quickly that the media that was
coming to you
was around the clock and probably
invasive
what
my relationship to media has been
through lacrosse which
was and is still considered by many a
niche sport
that when i graduated from college in
2008
the game wasn't even being distributed
on broadcaster cable television
and i had a facebook fan page that was
picking up tens of thousands of
followers organically and it kind of
tipped me off to
um
you know to
to build or to create a life in doing
something that i loved i needed to
build the media on my own
and so my relationship i think was
different from yours and its origin but
in the end yeah privacy is super
important i just think being a lacrosse
player versus one of the most famous
athletes uh of the last decade in your
case i can turn that on and off when i
want to more easily than you could huh
that's an interesting perspective yeah i
mean i'm going here because i think that
well first it was obvious to me that
there was that this you know you
are so
ingrained in the promotion of it in the
explaining of
lacrosse in
in and then also just i think you know
just to help people have someone to
cheer for like when i watched that video
of you being at the indy 500 i know that
colton herta knew who you were because
he's probably watched tons of your
videos like
he played red cross and he could follow
you so he knew you well
um
and so but i think that the reason why
it's important is because this is what
gave you
it's
first and foremost it's what's giving
you the ability to promote lacrosse but
it's also probably what gave you the
idea to even start a league like the
fact that you had the vision
so
you know i know i'm kind of putting the
cart before the horse talking about all
the background of it and the videos and
promoting and the vision um before we
even talk about the league itself but i
think that that came first yeah i mean
it would be like if you were that's
needed totally if if you
when you won your first indie card race
and that was such a big scene imagine
having done that in front of a quarter
of
the stands full and
no coverage across sportscenter
you would have been like okay this was
it doesn't displace the meaning for you
as an athlete like when i won a
championship 10 years ago it feels like
the championship two years ago
but we care so much about what we do and
we know that other people
are just like us because you've met the
next young girls and boys that are
aspiring to be the next danica patrick
and i've met the next young girls and
boys that are aspiring to be the next
professional lacrosse player so they're
there they just didn't know how to
access the pro game in my case so
you know we learn as athletes along the
way through our sports sponsorship in
agency representation and pr and
learning how the teams in my case are
run and the league's run in your case
how the tours are being put together we
learn about the business there was a
need for me
based on how i'm ingrained to
to either amplify it or fix it
if i was an indycar racer i would never
even have thought to have done that
because the business was working right
and it was it would have been more about
okay how do i continue to grow so i had
this like complex
as professional lacrosse players like
damn what i'm doing is so much fun
fulfilling am i having to scrape the
bottom of a bit of the barrel for a
living yes but it shouldn't be this way
and i was seeing what the ufc did we're
seeing what f1 has done in the last
seven years we're seeing what you know
even like a lot of individual sports
that have continued to grow
um in team sports like the wnba it's
like the market is out there
and it's not this massive moat in the
90s where was just football basketball
baseball
so i had no sports business experience i
knew how to build companies yeah
because it was
you know it was just applying
problem solving to
any scenario so a lot of like reading
and researching and networking and
asking questions but i knew it was out
there and to your point
when we were creating media through our
social channels originally was just to
talk to our fans
and then it became like oh damn through
the comment section and other things
like people really like lacrosse how do
i how do i then help it become better
so
where did this
business mind come from i mean
or capability even
yeah i think that it came from really
two areas one is
when i was out of school
uh
the rookie wage that i signed for was
like 6 500 bucks and then
you know
sorry a year yeah for the season yeah it
was brutal like we were can't even live
on that that's not even minimum wage no
it's not and i had a uh i had a job at
the time with a real estate company i
was a
an analyst kind of like back my way into
a job because that's what
a lot of athletes who even playing
division one at their highest level if
there's not a pro game then you move on
to the workforce it's like the
enterprise commercials are always
pitching on like athletes going into the
next stage of their life when there's
nothing else to to take the next step
and that's how lacrosse was um but i was
like
you know figuring out how to
pursue being what i wanted to be at the
time was the best player in the world
and one of the best to ever play
we had world championships every four
years so i was training my ass off but
also
to point number one trying to figure out
how to get a reasonable wage
and so
yeah part two is
all right well if you if you're known in
your sport what are some ways you can
make extra money well through
appearances through endorsements and
then through what i was running at the
time a camp in clinic business so i was
basically traveling the country teaching
kids and families and coaches
lacrosse and then you know picking up
registration fees from it so i was
[ __ ] scrapping like doing [ __ ] that
like i bet you and i don't really want
to do because it's pretty humbling to
like
travel to indianapolis with a bag and
like some lacrosse pennies and work with
like 150 kids and like
you know
uh stay at a like a a pretty like you
know
a grimy hotel and like try to like have
nice margins and so i was learning the
principles of business by necessity and
then i would pick up everything along
the way
with my under armour sponsorship and
then a red bull sponsorship is they got
access to stuff that other athletes at
the highest level were doing i was going
oh this is what it could look like
well i mean endorsements and showing up
and getting paid for things tends to be
a lot easier
when
the sport is bigger and the name is big
you know what i mean like that so like
as that being a way to make money it's
also still not easy when the the
the eyes aren't on what you're doing as
much so
you know teaching kids is probably
you know definitely a lot of a lot of
that time yeah yeah i mean there's a ton
of time
but i had to think about things like
marketing my camp business and um you
know building an llc to protect myself
legally and taking out insurance on
fields and
customer service with parents who wanted
to cancel the day before because their
kid got injured and like all that [ __ ]
was running through
my
um
small company at the time and i hired an
assistant
and uh and was figuring it out but on
the sponsorship side i know
from speaking to different brand
managers i've worked with they
it was because of that curiosity was
also you know when you get
when you're constantly
you know a second or third tier athlete
and this is just to give people are
listening
how like either closer if they're
younger and listening how uh how long it
felt away but it feels close to you and
i was 2008 to like 2011 or 12.
um and that was that was when people
were just like there's professional
lacrosse that exists and
um and like who is this guy and so you
you you build thicker skin
so i was probably a little bit
more
um
maybe ambitious and uh
and almost like negligent in the way
that i would work with my brand partners
and ask them for approval on like
marketing assets and like oh who is the
photographer who's the videographer how
are we shooting this can i look at the
storyboard and i was always kind of
interested in that side of the business
and maybe it was because i never thought
that i'd be able to make it too long in
professional lacrosse so what i was
going to do next but all of those bits
and pieces were now a part of what i do
today with the pol because it's
running a league there's so many
aspects to it
where did you grow up
i grew up in gaithersburg maryland so a
small rural town and outside of dc
we didn't have much lacrosse and i
played every sport that our parents
would get us into played at the rec
level swam did track and field um
soccer lacrosse later basketball ton
my brother played baseball we played
street hockey we did all the [ __ ] that
kids don't do today
because we didn't have mobile devices
our dad didn't let us play video games
and we were outside playing sports
that's awesome i mean that's part of the
story though is that that's what you
know that's so your brother did i
was he is he a very business-minded guy
too is he yeah and and he investor
entrepreneur himself totally and he uh
he went to dartmouth on a on like a
football recruiting invitation uh ivies
don't give scholarships so
um we ended up my dad ended up really
grinding and my mom to help him get in
there and through it but he's built some
um relationships that have gone above
and beyond in in way of what we've been
able to create today but out of school
he was invited to one nfl camp and he
was with the arizona cardinals and then
they passed
um and so he was just like all right
back to that enterprise commercial i'm
going from division one double a
football to
got a job in real estate and then left
that and started an entrepreneurial
career
um is he older or younger he's older
he's two years older but by the time we
started building the pll together which
was in 2017 you know he had booked 10
years of entrepreneurial experience wow
yeah so it was super helpful i could
bring
you know subject matter experience and
expertise in lacrosse and media
marketing savvy and then he was building
the bones of the business and
fundraising and such
wow
um
do you think that you'd be where you are
without him
i wouldn't have found it in someone else
or would it have taken longer i mean
it's a great question i don't think i
would be playing
professional lacrosse without him i mean
him and i were basically attached at the
hip when we were younger and fought all
the time we had to put a rule together
by the time we were
in our teens that we had to be on the
same team
and like neighborhood ball oh because
otherwise yeah we were flashed all the
time yeah i mean all the time even over
stupid [ __ ] like are you guys the same
size are you bigger than him he's
i'm a little bit taller than him now um
but he was always bigger than me and he
was a d tackle at dartmouth and the
captain of the football team and he was
300 pounds okay so he was a it was a big
dude and now you know he's caught all
the weight since
um leaving football but yeah i mean he
could throw me across the room pretty
easily
um and so we had that rule and then even
today like when we
ever get into like some type of
exhibition
um we'll play on the same team
but so sport was a was a connective
tissue for us and
to answer your question on the pll
wouldn't have done it
i don't think another business partner
would have worked either
because it was so hard
especially in the first year and a half
because we basically took over
the existing league at the time the
league that was paying me 6 500 as a
rookie to play
uh and we took most of the top players
in that league in year one
to come join us and there was just mud
slinging like behind the scenes between
their ownership groups
and and mike and i and so we got in we
had like many of many of late nights um
stressed
uh finger-pointing
you know i was still you know really
focused on playing at the highest level
and he needed me to and the league
needed me to and so there was always
this dynamic of
me training for three hours a day and
him being like when the [ __ ] are you
coming back to the office like i need
your eyes and ears on this and
uh and it's always been disproportionate
up to that degree because i still play
and he right boulder's a lot of the
business
where do you guys um where's the sort of
delegation of
work what are you what is what are you a
little better at or have a better eye
for him what is he a little better at
yeah that's also how our relationship
has evolved as uh more mature people i
would say from when we were in our teens
fighting all the time
natural
yeah
but you know he's he's really egoless
and we also appreciate each other's
skill sets and are
are always complementing each other it's
like a romantic relationship or any type
of partnership that you're in and
there's a reason why in a lot of
business schools they bring in
relationship therapists to teach a
course that's often mandated whether
it's at gsb or harvard business school
is your business partner is yeah it's
your second wife or second husband
and um
and
so you have to be thoughtful you have to
check in you have to be complimentary
you can't take advantage of that person
super open and honest
and that's gotten to us a place where
you know i feel this almost daily i get
to take part in the sexy side of the
business like i oversee our media and
content strategy and marketing
um and you know kind of
we call it our ops but basically the
product on field
and mike does everything from
fundraising to management of our entire
org chart to
um you know kind of overseeing legal in
hr
um and like general is he's better
but is that what he's better at because
i think i found this but i found this
with
um
you know in my own life where i look at
some jobs that people are doing and i'm
thinking that must not be that fun they
freaking love it like there are certain
aspects of life thank god everybody's
different because there's somebody that
loves the details somebody that loves
being on camera somebody you know so
just because
what he's doing is not what would be fun
for you doesn't mean that that's not fun
for him and that's where like everyone
has their role and so as i'm kind of
curious how where your your main role
with pll
and
your own brand like yeah
i mean that's and that's what's made it
so great is it just really fit nicely
right he
he runs the business i
basically
think through and execute the strategy
and the media and the distribution of it
and that's what you need in sports i
mean
we're a a
inside outside business not every take
some of the most valuable companies in
the world the most valuable companies in
the world
are are technology companies and they're
sas businesses so they sell software as
a service
and you basically have this product as
an entrepreneur that you build and you
test with your engineers and you hope to
achieve what they call product market
fit
where there's enough consumers out there
that like your product and then you
raise money to hire to basically build a
huge sales organization so you can grow
revenue and then you sell your business
and it's pretty linear and you don't
have to deal with this like pr and
like the whether or not people know the
founders or they're consuming the
product and judging it
sports entertainment entertainment is is
hollywood and music
really
are so public-facing and the ability to
constantly gather attention but
galvanize the attention of your consumer
drives the value of your company
and that is what la crosse has never
done in its professional existence it's
what the nfl the nba
um the nhl indycar nascar all these uh
properties have grown to become
successful at but then there's the whole
side of the company that's behind the
scenes
and that's making sure that the business
has profitability or at least a path to
profitability
and is managing shareholders and is you
know communicating with the players and
all this other stuff that is so heavy
and so dense and that's what he leads
and he's built for it because he's
really really talented at it and he's
sharp around seeing the forest with the
trees
one of the things that is interesting
and different about
pll is that the players have equity is
that right they are equity their
shareholders in the in the company whose
idea was that and how is that working i
mean i know it's early on and that the
league started and officially under you
uh in 2019 right summer of 19. yep
but how is that working yeah i mean and
whose idea was that you know and why
like why would you not want to just own
the whole thing yeah well
so it's a good question why because when
we
when we went about building the pll we
saw the opportunity in our industry
which was lacrosse and sports business
and sports media we could have just
built another
mousetrap another version of what's out
there for team sports leagues they're
called trade associations
and found ownership groups and launch
teams and markets and probably would
have been okay
but we were also at this moment in time
and this is like ten and a half years
into the social media era where the
power dynamic has shifted from teams and
owners to players and entertainers and
you've seen that come about through
athletes investing athletes taking
equity and brand partnerships and
athletes owning teams and
realizing that it doesn't have to be a
fleeting career which is where sports
has had all the leverage over us for so
long is the average expectancy of most
athletes is two to four years totally
and so what we were like is hey if we if
we are
innovators like we say we are and if we
want to disrupt sports let's do more
than just start a new league
let's change the way that maybe
professional sports at the team level
function
with talent and
so we're a true single entity meaning
that the
the governing body of the pll so our
capitalization table
um has everything from owners to our pll
employees to our players on it and the
teams are are owned by that overarching
body at some point it may shift to
a trade association or what the mls has
had which are still single entity but
they have investor operators which are
essentially their owners
that then govern their teams
it can get a little bit complicated but
what we do with the equity is we
basically are for single entity much
like uh a technology startup in silicon
valley we'll just treat our players like
our employees and if they're coming in
early and putting all the sweat equity
on the field why not as part of their
comp package we give them
uh stock and so
mike built the mechanics of it but it
was i think it was both of our ideas to
to again to take advantage of starting a
league
in 2019 and what might that look like
with the trend of what we're seeing in
sports
how has it helped you do you think or
has it yeah i mean i think is it
difficult to tell at this point yeah i
think you could look at it both ways i
think it is still early and difficult to
tell but
i think what we get early on is just
greater participation from players and
less divisiveness
i mean i tell people
you know at least analogously
there's no really rhyme or reason when a
commissioner walks out to hand out the
trophy or the mvp or they're booed
by the fans you know and like you know
one of the i think probably the most
long-standing television show at least
in in the us and successful by many
accounts is the office which taps into
the psychology of us
as people to hate your boss or like when
you're in the workplace understanding
division of authority and i think that
lives in sports like players are drafted
and they're like all right it's us
versus the owners or you know i'm my gm
who's deciding on my wage is my enemy
and
uh what we got from giving players
shares in the business was like hey
we're in this together and when we have
brand partners come in and they're doing
uh content shoots on the grounds of game
weekends like our players are much more
willing and excited to be a part of it
because they know that as the company
grows then their value creation grows
too
and that was our bet because we knew
like it's really really competitive out
there you know it wasn't about beating
major league lacrosse which was the
original
league it was about getting to a place
where summer sport were competing with
mls and we're competing with you know
the nba in the nhl when they're
finishing up in june and like how do we
take a slice of those revenues from
television contracts to sponsorship and
um you know the good news is they
continue to grow
and and create a bigger pie and we're
just trying to you know participate in
it as well
the fact that it came that it started
officially in 2019 like you probably in
last year were going oh
[ __ ]
like
i i'm did you
how did it what happened like what
i mean obviously
i feel like you probably feel like it's
starting this year almost just with the
way that it went
um i mean uh i'm just thinking content
content content you maybe filmed extra
personal content but like for stuff on
the field and getting in the monks with
the fans and you know i know that it's
also a not a city-based sport in that
the whole league
goes around together correct that's
right
so
um but just getting to the fans in
general i mean
[ __ ] right what happened i mean if if
when mike and i were on the fundraising
trail in 2017
if we had a crystal ball that said we
would hit be hit with this global
pandemic in 2020 we'd be like no we're
not doing this and our investment we
wouldn't be able to raise money either
it was yeah it was hell
and we're still like meeting with our
kobe committee on a weekly basis and our
ceo leads that process and you have
different variants now and it's it's
just do you you know what i always have
to say this because watching sports and
i love all sports so um but when i watch
sports and maybe i'm gonna get in
trouble for this but i don't really care
um
there must be so much like pomp and
circumstance just like
doing what is politically correct versus
what is actually sensical because when i
watch like basketball just ended
recently but but watching them be on the
side with their masks sitting next to
each other and then being on the court
together and you know i mean you just
watch that and you're like this is not
sensical it's ridiculous and this is all
for appearance purposes
like you must be over the [ __ ] of
what it takes to just like play the
sport yeah it it's super complicated it
goes back to that public and private
profile that we have to have as a
business
very few companies have to juggle that
but the reality is when we're
casted on nbc owned and operated
broadcast and cable and peacock and same
thing with the nba through turner and
espn
is like you just have people watching
you and
um and you have to
demonstrate code
because if you don't the flip side is is
you can get crushed especially if
there's a slip
and i agree on like the nonsensical
stuff can be a little bit inane it can
feel a name where like guys are wearing
their masks on the sideline and then
they're like on the floor and they take
their mask off and you're just like well
i don't get it yeah it kind of reminds
me of the school system from time to
time like you have to
you have to educate you have to get in
line you have to do things certain ways
uh to make sure that
at least like the boxes are checked the
other piece is for us as a league um we
actually take it out of our hands as as
operators and so we brought on an
external covered medical committee that
makes decisions and that way like we
have the professionals doing it and we
adhere to
their policies and uh that's that's
super important and it's at least you
don't make the decisions because you
know that is always a political disaster
and also then say there's a slip up
right or something happens it's it's
it's why in sports and maybe you can
share your own perspectives of this or
or how how you operate or perhaps even
the arc that you've had as an athlete
getting to where you are and being like
one of the best of that's ever played
versus when you were younger is that
there's so much stuff i can this is from
my perspective that you do early on
because you just can't give someone a
reason
yeah and then later on you just go you
know what and and then of course you
know this is not applying this is not
the same thing for you know protocols
and things like that but it's out of
your hands and then you don't have to
worry about being judged for it where
you know as an athlete you just make
sure that you do everything possible
that no one can go that's why yeah yeah
for sure and that's that's part of our
our job as entertainers and i remember
peter gruber telling me that early on
when i was
pitching him on investing in the league
and he didn't
um but he grew up playing lacrosse and
and does think
uh highly of of what we're creating
but he had said a couple of things when
i was like kind of pitching him our
media strategy
he was like sports is not entertainment
he's like sports is show business like
this is this is full-on show business
the business you're getting into
and the other thing he was like can we
figure out how to play lacrosse without
helmets which is a whole another
conversation
unlikely because the the ball is so
dense and there's concussion fears and
all this other stuff but he but his
point around show business is if you
think about athletes who are personified
globally a lot of them is non-helmet
sports unless you're a quarterback
and quarterbacks you know were honestly
they were a crop that tried to unionize
before the nfl pa it was the
quarterbacks club and and yeah and there
is like a dynamic
uh between quarterbacks and and other
skill players because they just are the
most well known they're in the press
conferences the most they have the ball
in their hands the most and people know
what their face looks like helmet sports
is difficult soccer basketball i know
what you mean
exactly there you go i mean if it
weren't for the media outside of the car
if it wasn't for the interviews if it
wasn't for the talk shows if it wasn't
for you know my version of the the
production my version of the
content content content um people
wouldn't know me either and you know
that's i was i you know that's
definitely i used to say that racing had
a problem because we weren't a city
meaning you know people and maybe you
guys
have are going to face the same sort of
thing but
you know you cheer for uh you know you
cheer for the bears because you live in
chicago right or you ch but i don't as a
race car driver you don't live anywhere
so you know nobody cheers for me because
i'm from illinois um i don't have all of
illinois behind me so i feel like that's
a reason but you you know pointing out
the helmet thing that's absolutely
another i mean if you don't have an
image there's nothing for someone to
sort of grab onto and if you're wearing
your helmet you're probably not being
interviewed so it's only through the
other stuff that you do which
is hard to get you know you have to it's
kind of the cart before the horse it's
like you know something that you're
doing has to be popular enough that
people want to actually talk to you 100
i mean you bring up a really interesting
point maybe we'll we'll have
conversations behind the scenes
so uh so i can figure this out a little
bit more uh we can't give away all of
our sauce
but
like we used to think about
like you and your sport and other
athletes and individual sports and say
see you don't need geo
because if someone has such a big
audience
and their narrative is told away from
the racetrack then people all over the
world are going to be danica patrick
fans and not run the risk of if danica
is set up in chicago well because you
know boston hates chicago
she's going to lose that potential fan
base so
that was the view we had however we also
look at the city model now which we
think will grow into at some point it's
just at our stage we needed every
lacrosse fan in the world to have a
reason to support the pol at the time
and we didn't want to ostracize any by
when we launched six teams only in six
cities but you know the grass is greener
always and i guess to you to your other
other question i didn't answer because i
went off on a tangent on uh peter guber
is is like
they're what i run up against
consistently now and it's helping me
grow as a as a business person and
person
is that
being an athlete and being talent is
so much different than being an operator
or the owner
and while i've been doing both it's been
really hard but it gives me
a much more empathetic look
on both sides than what other leagues
have which is like clear division of
church state
and so
where we make decisions that as a league
is much different than where i make
decisions as a player or other athletes
do
we we like as a lead you have to get it
right
and you have to be a lot of times
neutral and you have to be um you know
cordial respectful you have to have um
you know customer service in place for
all ranges of experiences
um you can't
uh ostracize any cohort of people and
you just that's like how you're measured
and you have to roll out product
um players
you know their personal opinions
actually matter and matter a ton
and so and they all they matter more
than ever i think now because we're
starting hopefully starting to get to a
place
after 2020 where we can recognize that
every human's experience is unique to
the next and we develop our thoughts and
our
decisions based on not just how we were
raised or what market we were raised in
or who we dated or who our friends were
or how our parents were
we actually have these
decisions that are kind of baked in us
from our parents parents and their
parents parents especially for those
that came over from other countries
and um
and what our country tries to do is
slate us into
binary thinking totally and it's
impossible to achieve so yeah nobody
actually fits into one little box either
in any way
it's like you know even if we're going
like red or blue like in the country
like don't we kind of want the most
republican democrat the most democratic
republican i mean don't we actually want
kind of in the middle and i'm i think
this kind of is across the board like
completely polarizing figures have their
niche and have their group but they're
not the masses like right you know so i
totally agree yeah i mean the look the
democratic system that we have in place
when it works it works better than any
other country in the world
but as it polarizes um it becomes really
really challenging
and we've seen it
on the hill more in the last decade and
two decades than we even saw than the
decades that preceded that if you look
at electoral college map in the 90s it
was much different than it is today and
so you could make a
a conclusion that like wow our country's
gotten more divisive
and like
isn't that the opposite of the way that
we should be growing and evolving we
should be coming together more so what
are they i agree what are the the
divides um i mean i posted some story
the other day that was like you know the
real pandemic is the division and you
know i mean yes there's real things
going on but it's kind of just a point
to be made that um you know even i mean
we're not going to go down this road but
even from a from a from a from a
vaccination standpoint the people that
get it do it to be healthy and the
people that don't do it to be healthy
like we're all like we're all actually
so much closer than we realize but
there's so many things it could be
sports that divide us it could be you
know like
you know michigan versus ohio right like
it could be there's so many different
things that create division and you're
totally right this is we're going in the
wrong direction and i wonder if it's um
i wonder if the way that it works in in
general is that there has to be such a
stretch
that you find the middle because there's
clearly being a stretch in lots of
different ways in our culture yeah yeah
i mean you look at it as as a spectrum
and the polarizing ends you look at it
as a pendulum too when when the pendulum
swings really high in one direction it's
going to swing back in the other at some
point
and that's how our lives go too and just
from um
from a psychology standpoint and like
buddhist theory is um you actually can't
feel happy without feeling sad
because if you were happy all the time
you would have no range and so your
happiness would feel like boredom and
when we do really well
and we experience what it means to do
really well
you're also going to swing down and do
poorly it's it's just the ebbs and flows
of life
yeah you can't know i mean you can't
know joy without pain you would have no
reference point no reference point and
uh and the acceptance of those swings
help us stay
grounded or temper
the bad and then we also should then
recognize that when we're in the good we
should temper the good
because if you can't have your cake and
eat it too you can't be like hey uh i
won the championship or i won the mvp
and like let me just bask in that for as
long as possible and then when [ __ ] hits
the fan i want to get out of there as
quick as possible no you can't so like
make sure and this may apply to people
who are finding themselves obsessed over
social and i've been like this before
um is we get it like focused on
engagement or impressions or views when
a video video that we post does really
well
and then like when [ __ ] doesn't go well
we're like depressed and sad or angry or
no one likes me and
and so just be mindful of the upswings
as much as you are the downswings that
will help you get through both
i love that you
uh talked about like buddhist theory and
what they believe is that is that
something you follow and you've read a
lot about
yeah i would no way consider myself an
expert in buddhism or hinduism but it uh
when i got into
really mindfulness and meditation
um i started studying that more because
it was helpful for me as an athlete that
would
stress
all the time um
you know and it was just i would imagine
that this is the case for for most
athletes certainly those at the top of
their game it's
i felt like this since high school but
it's
i love the week of training i love
practicing and if we had a saturday game
like thursday nights and friday nights
are the best and as soon as like the
game day turns
or just feel so much pain around like
the outcome
because i put so much into something
talk about that's binary in sports we're
gonna know the result
in in you know eight hours when the
game's over
and i would just
have so much exhaust and these fumes
just hit hit hit
and uh and then get out and play and
fortunately like more times than not
i've done it well then i haven't but
when i do it well
it was like met my expectations and move
on and i want more constantly and when i
do orderly it would sit on me like a
cloud for weeks and sometimes years
and i was just like this isn't right
like one how do i
relieve some of these game day stressors
that i feel
and then two is how do i get the [ __ ]
over myself
you know like
people who care about me or lacrosse and
the team that was on yeah they're pissed
when we lose but then they did go back
to their life like the world doesn't
revolve around us no matter what you do
and that type of like
mentality and approach to solving for
that
it taps into like origins of buddhism
and so that's where uh i find a lot of
relief in that wow how did you
i'm not gonna say you stumbled on it but
what led you there versus
going to church or versus i'm going to
find some other way to get this sort of
um built up pressure or anxiety out i
don't know
could have taken it any direction you
wanted but you went that one how did it
how did that become the thing yeah i
mean i grew up
pretty stout catholic and my dad is is
still very much practicing
uh christian and and the rest of our
family is and the principles you get in
faith whether it doesn't matter the
denomination
are
i think you're like strong moral fiber
decision making care for your neighbor
work ethic and those things uh really
are amplified in sport work ethic piece
care for your teammates your neighbor
and like good decision-making
um
but i found that like where i leaned on
you know my faith growing up was
just saying that like
you know god has a plan it's going to be
better pray for a better outcome
and like
and i just felt like that that wasn't
solving for my pain
yeah right it's not um
it's like a very temporary band-aid but
it's not root cause right it's just like
huh it's like some it's like a mantra
almost right
and
um you know i'm still a practicing
christian but i felt like related to
sport
that i i there was this was just how i
was feeling and there wasn't any
intervention that was going to help it i
was the one who was going to help it
and in 2014
uh there was like two things that
happened back to back i was playing in
my second world championship with team
usa we had by most counts the best team
to ever play
and we got upset in the final and and
lost the gold medal to canada and the
following week went back to my pro team
in boston and i broke my foot so like at
the time i lost what was considered the
biggest game
in like american lacrosse history and i
was
you know the top player on the team
and i broke my foot and it was like okay
my career is over
um and i went into this like depressive
state and was up on my couch all day for
you know four months and my agency at
the time was like i think you should
meet this sports psychologist that works
with some of our other athletes
and that's where it started but it was
more focused on like hey your career's
not over you're 28 you're at the top of
your game this happens a lot of athletes
you're going to be fine
and it led to
other things like dealing with
frustrations on the field being more
mindful and present in the locker room
building better relationships with
teammates
um and then that led me into meditation
and then i was using an app called
headspace at the time yeah i've used
that yeah and my like
kind of entrepreneurial mind was like i
wonder who's the guy who started this
what's the business like is it
successful so i looked up andy puddakum
and i read his story and he was a
converted
uh christian or some denomination over
to a monk and then
found a business partner that he was
helping um just on the psychology side
say hey let me leave my ad agency and
i'm like selling headspace right now um
[Music]
yeah and it was it was a story for me
and and you know fast forward to
actually you asked about 2020
so red bull was still one of my partners
and they knew that i'd been on the app
for seven years or so and and uh they
connected me with andy puticum and i had
a private
session with him which was like a dream
um so yeah life works its way out in so
many wow
well i mean
you know i feel like the basis of
buddhism
has so much to do with the self and
accountability and going within yourself
and
you know i even just think about you you
starting the lacrosse league premier la
costa lacrosse league that
it's about you just said to yourself
kind of like you just did
well why don't i just do it myself right
why don't i just start the league it's
it's accountability it's something you
can do yourself instead of looking at it
in the other way which is it's someone
else's problem which i i i'm there's so
many wonderful things about all
religions i just think that
you know there's some downfalls too and
allowing some like putting your problem
onto somebody or something else to solve
it is just not going to fix it and so if
you were to look at
lacrosse and say
oh i can't believe this isn't bigger i
can't believe and so instead it's like
this mindset or this new
paradigm that you live in where you go
hmm
how could i do this what what could i do
to it's like full accountability and i
think that as people we're completely
limitless and it's totally our
environment it's our it's our
our upbringing as well as our friends
and the people that we know and our
social situation and where we live and
there's so many things that sort of
craft our
opinion or perspective of how things are
supposed to go but it's limitless
and when you start to like realize that
you just go oh i don't know i'll just
start a league then yeah me that feels
like a like a branch of buddhism in a
way
yeah
in a way for sure i think that
i mean and to be honest i was a part of
the cohort of people that would always
go why isn't it better why don't they
just do the work and
uh man for for building a league it
actually was
so much work and more than we even
accounted for
and there were many times where we
kind of sat across the room from each
other and mike and i just been like
this is this is too much and also no
wonder the former owners were in many
cases like [ __ ] this and we're not going
to do this and we'll just continue to
invest bare minimum and hopefully
um you know the pendulum swings in la
crosse's direction on its own which
historically has never happened in any
league not the nba
not the nfl not major league baseball
there's no professional sport that has
gained momentum from bottom up growth
those sports are actually olympic sports
and they only come every four years
there's a reason why
i saw lots of them and i'm like that's a
sport there are so many amazing sports
out there that haven't figured out the
professional side of it yet and they go
away after
well then how do you do it if it's not
bottom up then what is it
that's that's the that was the challenge
we were like all right we've got to
raise capital we've got to hire a bunch
of hard-working employees to roll our
[ __ ] sleeves up every single day take
20 no's every single day and go out and
try to build this thing
and it's going to take a ton of energy
it's going to be more
uh
more difficult than it is easy and will
only get more difficult it's basically a
startup
exactly i mean it's it's building a
company it's the same thing
if if we weren't as athletes growing up
so consumed by the fun of our sport
and how much we enjoyed it
we would have taken a step back and been
like god damn look how much work we're
putting into this every single day
and it's sometimes the the own fault of
us as a league
and athletes that
we only often get depicted for their
greatness and all of the progress
and that creates this false narrative in
a way people i've talked about with don
garber who's become a mentor and
um and friend and he's the commissioner
of mls and what they've done over the
last 25 30 years and what we see now
is certainly not what it was in the 90s
and he still says like every day they're
grinding and making decisions and
figuring out how to solve coven like we
did and play games
and the other side of it is their
athletes and the audience thinks that
they sit at the top of an ivory tower
and it's like you know playing a video
game and super fun and it never is it
just isn't it's hard so what makes a
sport popular
oof
well
not wearing helmets yeah not wearing
helmets
you've got to have meaningful
distribution
so one of the reasons why we built the
tour based model in the first place so
we could get a network deal
because if we went building from the
ground up in cities with individual
owners we would have had to either
rent out stadiums in each market or
build stadiums which have taken more
capital
the renting of venues makes it really
difficult for any league to build their
schedule
i mean absent in the nfl which basically
has carte blanche
like even the mls that owns all their
venues they take till middle of january
to announce their schedule because
there's so many back and forth on
optimizing who's home who's away at what
time
and then you go to the networks and say
here's our game schedule well if you
don't have any product market fit if
we're a startup as i talked about
earlier
i.e ratings we're not going to get a
network deal because we have nothing to
present in 2017 when mike and i were
pitching our story so instead we went
this tour based model means we're going
to go to boston and take out gillette
for three days do you have any windows
that are available on nbc or nbc sports
that weekend and if so boom that's when
our games are
and so we kind of did like this inside
out model right to capitalize on how do
you make it popular will you get on tv
and then the second is you get brand
brands to come in and invest and we
treat our i say invest because we treat
our sponsors like investors instead of
sponsors
um they're investing in the growth they
get equity
they don't um but like that's how we
treat them right and and and like we we
plus them up we give them a ton of value
we take care of them
um because we know it's a different type
of investment that they're making it's
it's unproven especially in the first
two seasons
and then if you get your brand partners
to come in and they're starting to
market lacrosse like gatorade's doing
for us then all of a sudden like young
kids that are seeing gatorade typically
market soccer basketball and football
they're going oh damn you know lacrosse
maybe maybe if i can be a gatorade
athlete one day i'll i'll have a
lacrosse stick
and that's how you like build it from a
media marketing standpoint and then we
always felt like if we could
roll out the red carpet if that was our
version of that by elevating wages
giving players equity and being on tv
then the product on field is going to be
kick-ass and
people are going to want to watch
lacrosse more because they like what
they see
i also think that it takes personalities
no doubt
um
i think that's probably what i was
benefited from was people knew me people
had a taste of my personality um at
least one part of my personality which
is probably why people afterwards when i
interview drivers now they're like you
seem really
deep and spiritual and stuff is that new
i'm like no
but there was no space for that you know
that wasn't like you know something to
promote but people still saw a side of
my personality and so they you know they
can decide to cheer for you or not and
um and so i think that's probably
your popularity is that people know you
like i watched enough videos that i get
your personality to some degree you know
i i
because i saw you in a raw form i saw
you
i saw you being natural i saw you at
home i saw you cooking i saw you you
know i saw you talking to a group of
people at a school like i can see these
i can see this sort of i can see your
personality and so
you know i've i've found that to be true
too and racing itself as well when a
driver you don't always have to put it
out there yourself
like you said sometimes there's enough
opportunities to show it um but for for
ones who don't get that you can i mean
that's why there's like youtube
sensations they're not on tv they're
just showing their personality and so if
you have a cool skill which all your
players have cool skill and then they
show their personality then
their people are going to follow and be
curious that's why colton heard it at
the indy 500 wanted to meet you because
he
saw your personality and so i've always
thought this to be true is that you know
people that aren't willing to be
vulnerable honest raw
emotions up and down whatever they are
and show them
um and somewhat promote themselves and
realize that doing the interviews and
showing up to things is important
you know i mean
it's about the effort that you put in to
show people who you are to cheer for you
it's it's one of the
you're 100 right i mean
what
really jordan did but you could say
magic and bird to the nbas of the 80s
was astronomical i mean the nba in the
80s had a horrible reputation
and they couldn't fill arenas and then
those stars came in
and david stern at the time rest in
peace switched his strategy from
building up teams to creating
enlargement of players and if you look
at what conor mcgregor did to the ufc
even though they were trajecting upward
and what you were doing in racing and
and you you see personalities that take
a sport to another level
um
some of those i mean it's like finding a
needle in the haystack to a degree of
the caliber of people that i just
mentioned where it's perfectly best at
what they do
amazing personality relatable ambitious
and you're like [ __ ] you know this this
is amazing and
um but you know we're still living in an
era where
if you're a professional athlete if you
want to
get as much out of your
in the grand scheme of things short
career
you've got to step up
it for in the form of media and you've
got to be available to your audience
many many athletes don't want to do that
they just want to focus on their craft
and that's okay they'll just never reach
the point of economic prosperity or
notoriety that's just honestly part of
our business if we believe that we're a
show business which sports just are
then you know you can participate for
skill only but you're just not going to
you know bust through the ceiling
i do have a question for you you like
did you struggle
with that notoriety related to your
ability to continue to perform i mean so
many people and talking about brand
integrations and sponsorship
so many people
they learned about godaddy they learned
the business they did so there's such a
great job but you
were a part of
that execution
and all the family you're building like
did that mess with you how were you able
to and what advice could you give to
athletes um
well
it's always so different when you're in
the middle of it i'm sure you don't feel
your
youtube or online presence like as a
weight when you're doing a video you're
just being you
so like i felt the same like i'd shoot a
commercial or we you know do him
you know
do whatever promotional material was
asked of me
um
it's actually kind of interesting
because i've seen this transition as
i've come out of racing where everyone
did it for me like everyone had their
own media plan they had their own
uh production schedule they had their
own creative direction
and i just showed up and so when i got
done i have these other companies
my wine my book whatever whatever things
that i've come out with since my podcast
i
never had a system in place to promote
anything because it was all done for me
so i just showed i would just show up
and so it never felt like
there was there was not a lot that went
into it i just showed up does that make
sense so you know you talk about like
showing up at a game and a whole week's
practice before you get there and so
much is on the line i didn't have that
it wasn't like i came up with some
massive media schedule for all these
things and my team did it and i'm like
okay here we go it's time i just showed
up
and so there was like less and less
emotional involvement because it wasn't
my id and it wasn't my team it wasn't my
labor it was all these companies and so
i guess that's probably part of why i
just never felt the sort of gravity or
the weight of anything is that it just
it just didn't have a lot of energy
behind it um it was all within the
racing and so of course when i show up
to a race and if it didn't go well i
mean the amount of times that i was like
bawling in my bus about the way
qualifying went or where a race went or
something like that you know
that happened but that was because that
was what i put the effort into not the
pr side and not the promotional side and
so
um and then i think just in general i
was always since i was
attractive to the media um for whatever
reasons i think
for whatever reasons
it's probably easier to tell from the
outside than the inside
but
i
was able to be myself all the time i
never felt like i had to over compensate
and cater to someone here or there it
was funny the other day uh ryan holiday
who has the daily stoic and i don't know
if you know he is um
ryan's a good friend of mine oh really
yeah he was interviewing brad keselowski
so he dm'd me and was like hey i'm
interviewing brad keselowski he's a
nascar driver anything you want me to
know or i should ask him so i gave him a
bunch of info and then but one of the
things i said was like don't let him
give you some [ __ ] nascar race car
driver answer like oh you know some
throw away and so he did that and i
think he said that brad said well since
i know i can't just give you some bs
answer and then he goes there was some
xyz that played into this decision like
he made him give more and so
i never
i never had to do the [ __ ] answers
like it was and so it was kind of the
cart before the horse thing i think
people like to interview me because i
didn't give those [ __ ] answers and
so you saw my personality and i'm going
on and on but i think that's a lot of
the reason why i was able to be in the
position that i was is because i was
myself from the beginning and i never
had i never changed i never you know i
was always the same me you know so it
wasn't there was never uh and that's
also my personal life too there's no
course correction there's no like oh
guess what danica was doing you know in
the off season like yes what you see is
what you get and so yeah and i think
that's more rare um and a quality of
yours that you brought to a world that
had been around for a long time is like
we we often get asked like who our
sports idols were and
there's this tendency
well there's two things one
people think that we're natural or born
entertainers or marketers because we're
on screen
and i always say like there's there's
nothing that depicts
uh the difference between an athlete and
an entertainer is when you every off
season you see like galas or or like
fashion runways for charities and they
and they bring like nfl players and nba
players and people like oh you're used
to performing in front of crowds and
stuff and you're gonna be great on the
runway and we're like have our hands in
our pockets nervous as hell looking
around and like you know see an athlete
do a cameo entourage how many runways
have you walked on
small ones and small ones
in my
hometown but
yeah but like you see athletes do cameos
on screen and you're like why
why is there a disconnect well when
we're on screen doing what we do every
day we don't even think about being on
screen and we're just great at what we
do and it becomes seamless but we're not
natural entertainers and even the
transition from athletes to
supposed to be good on social
you need to like help them understand
that
and so
uh what what you what sounds like what
you did
which is different than a lot of
athletes because we're not born
entertainers is we look to those sports
idols and how they handle interviews and
we try to do the same thing and i see
that a lot with athletes as they
are performing or trying to be people
who they are not
and um
yeah and it's rare that you have someone
who just comes in on a bash and is like
this is who i am
and that's equality well i i've thought
a lot about this in a lot of different
facets but it applies to this but
when
you
are catering to someone or something it
could be
your sponsor it could be a relationship
a partner and whatever you think that
they want whenever you're catering
you're not actually you
and there's nothing for someone there's
no
integrity and essence and transmission
of truth
in that because you're not you you're
trying to be something or buddy else
and the best thing that anyone could do
is be themselves so what i always said
that
what i always thought at least about me
was that i don't know what makes me
interesting i don't know why people care
what i do i don't know why people are a
fan
other than the fact that all i know is
that
i'm authentic and that at least that
authenticity you might not agree with it
i might say or do things that you don't
agree with but at least you can sense my
authenticity
and i think that's what resonates people
are so afraid of being wrong or
being
um i don't know unattractive or being
um unintelligent or being goofy in some
way and so they're not them but really
it's it's it's being yourself and being
however it is that you're different i
mean that was my the name of my game
like i mean i know that's what helped me
get so far in racing was that i was
different being a girl it's the stuff
that makes you the most different that
makes you the most special and when
you're trying to be something you're not
and and trying to be like somebody else
the truth is you'll never be that person
you'll never be as good as that person
you at best can be second which makes
them not look at you it makes them still
look at them and so the more you can
embody who you are and be honest the
more it resonates with people and i
think that as a culture we're becoming
really sensitive to the frequency of
truth and we can tell when someone is
themselves and when they're not
yeah it's so well put and
there's not much to add outside of kind
of thinking through
the
the buddhist mindset but also
you know the challenges that athletes
have that are looking to find their
authentic voice
is that
you know we might be set up for disaster
with our agency and brands and publicism
you're talking like 21 year olds
that are coming into pro sports and it's
like i mean when you write a book you
just did this as well
it's like what's the theme what's the
one thing that you can expound on that
you're the expert and let's go along
there i don't care danica if you have 25
other interests we have to be very
concerned we have to know when you go
and speak and do your book tour that
this is the expertise that people are
going to get and you're like well
i feel kind of cornered now and so i
think for you and hopefully for me at
this stage as we've gotten
older and picked up different
experiences is we're finding and
continue to build our authentic voice
young people don't rush it
like and and to danica's point
like
be you in that moment and don't think
that that moment is permanent and that's
the only thing you stand for you will
grow you will change you will lose you
will win and like message might change
five years from now the people you date
will change five and ten years from now
and that's all good
and um and so let your authentic voice
evolve
but
um don't worry about like you know my
one of my favorite writers is brene
brown and she's oh yeah repeats
uh permanence pervasiveness
um and uh and uh what was the last one
pervasiveness permanence
and and person uh personification
so persona personalizing so our our mind
goes into those three areas whenever we
uh whenever we run into a problem
right we think that it's permanent and
it's never going to change it becomes
pervasive like oh i lost this game now
this person thinks i'm a loser and i'm
never going to get a starting position
again and my teammates think i suck
pervasiveness
and then uh and personalizing it is like
this is all on me and i did this and
you know i play in a [ __ ] team sport
and we lost by a goal in overtime and
it's because you know i missed that shot
in the fourth quarter it's like
every other minute in the game yeah so
that's how our brain works right yeah i
love renee brown and of course
the queen of vulnerability
so what have you realized about yourself
in this process and sort of
everything from
you know
showing more sides of yourself to being
squeezed in the professional world of
business
like what have you realized over time
are your truths at this point in time
well about who you are yeah
so it's dynamic and
i think like to to my point trying to
accept that it'll change and there are
things that i'm doing now that i will
dislike looking back 10 years from now
but i know what i what's made me the
athlete that i've been is i have this
internal fire
around competition and and work ethic
and i also have an internal fire of fear
and um i don't like that as a human
so like there's the athlete and then
there's the person that i'm trying to
continue to develop
and you don't really want to live a life
that's fear motivated that be pretty
destructive
for an athlete it's pretty [ __ ]
powerful
like the stuff that i would do and i've
tapped back into now the later stages of
my career
so that i don't
lose or so that i don't make a mistake
or turn the ball over
like that stuff
works in sports so then what i try to do
is okay
leave that on the field when you
practice around the game try to get
distance from that
when you're you know a person which is
most of my life
and uh and so why do you think why do
you think it works in sports but it
doesn't work in life and why do you
think it or why do you think that it
works in sports at all
well i think because of the binary
aspect of sport
and
the
and by binary it's not just one losing
it's like how you're performing on the
field the decisions that you make
everything can be pretty routinized and
in a playbook and you watch it on film
and it's like you did this you did this
that
um and and fear is such a powerful
motivator for me it just always was and
i think we could
yeah back into my genealogy of the way
that i was raised
i think oh that's my favorite favorite
area to go but we're not going to get
there
i mean
psychoanalyze people
yeah so and i think in in life
the idea that we made the right decision
or the wrong decision
especially on the wrong side
it's inherently impossible to know if
that's the case
maybe maybe not is the same right like
we don't know
even if we made a decision to do
something and it didn't turn out in our
favor we don't know if we didn't make
that decision what would have happened
we just never played it out so it can't
be
though the other one couldn't be right
it could have actually been worse
and i think that that's much different
than sport um and why so many people
love sport is like it's those moments in
life where we can
as fans and spectators get away from the
uncertainty of the world and the unknown
and focus on something for for two hours
that we know there's going to be an
outcome we know it doesn't actually
impact us i mean there are the die hards
that you know i'm not in sports i'm not
going to
lose a week of sleep because my favorite
team growing up lost the game it's just
not me
uh but you know i love those people they
bring a lot of passion to sport
um but like it's gonna be okay and so
it's it's very entertaining and fun to
to experience sport as a fan so that's
where i think the two differences are
and then
where i am authentically as a person is
is actually what we talked a little bit
about about like meeting people in the
middle
and i've learned this in building the
pll
is that the world
and life and business is actually about
compromise
and if you're ever in a place
relationally
uh in business
platonically where you feel like you got
a great deal call it that way
that means the other person didn't
and like you're not you're just not
going to move in the right direction if
you believe in partnerships the best
direction
and we say like at the pol the
sponsorship business isn't a isn't about
bringing on new sponsors it's actually a
renewal business when you bring people
in the door how good are you treating
them and if we get over on a sponsor
when we strike the deal and we get this
[ __ ] amazing contract
they're going back internally you can
bet they're going uh we may have
overpaid for this right and you're just
off to the wrong
to the wrong start
and um sport is not about compromise
sport is about i'm going to [ __ ] beat
you and beat you really badly because
the rankings will increase in that
direction and i'm going to be the
champion and so it's like rewarding
the the culture of of over performance
and outperforming your campaign are we
like perpetuating this division culture
by being athletes
the good news is that like there's only
one percent of one percent of us that
go from the lessons which are amazing in
sports at a young age so then it
becoming your profession right what you
and i experience
is when sport becomes your perfection or
your profession and you become a
perfectionist for a living
that like oh man now i'm like in the
fire and there are some negative things
about sport
um that can like become a part of our
life
well i can clearly tell that you are
able to separate and that you
compartmentalize your life in different
ways and
while sports incredibly important to you
and it's emotionally
you know taxing at times you know
there's another side of you that's able
to disconnect and go into the business
or go into these other aspects of your
life which keep the balance and so
there's all kinds of like
there's all kinds of micro macro on all
kinds of different levels in all
different spaces where you know on a
micro level you can be binary with your
sport and it's all in or out and it's
like win or lose but then you can
you can go into a different area
completely and you don't exist there and
so
that i and the fact that you you know
one of the big problems about athletes
is that and i think that's this is a
reason why they hang on is because they
don't know what they're going to do next
they don't have something else they've
put everything into this one sport and
they've not
i think knowing yourself is a hell of a
lot harder than people realize i'm just
saying that because i think i'm still
learning and i think it's always a bit
of a process but it took me into my
mid-30s before i really started to go oh
yeah these things make me really happy
and so
i think that you know you are
ahead of the game like the fact that you
have started the
pll and that you
have this entrepreneurial business side
mind of you
it's like the successful rc i i just
talked to some guys who started a
company called beam it's a cbd company
um
and they talked about how they were in
sports hockey and baseball and how they
just wanted to achieve highly at
something else and so
you know you just have that same dna and
so you'll be fine but it's it's really
about how can we how can you inspire
others to
learn more about themselves and be more
authentic and really know who they are
and so thank you for
embodying that and showing that and
expressing that in an articulate way
that helps people understand that there
are
there are sort of drawers for certain
aspects of you and knowing when to open
and close them as is part of the part of
the part of the balance yeah i really
appreciate you saying that um
and and this you know podcast went in so
many different directions i enjoyed it
and there was i think like you know was
a lot of things that you know when you
start when i start saying something i'm
like [ __ ] am i going there and this is
going to be weird but
like i think that goes to the
authenticity of what athletes experience
or hope to achieve
uh but the thing i'll
leave you with is
um yeah i obviously think about this
stuff a lot and i read a ton
but
i am so hard on myself and life is so
hard and
[ __ ] with me in so many different ways
all the time
and uh and so much that there's a phrase
that i hold on to and i like talk to my
therapist about it and she's like no
stop but i'm like i guess for those who
can't do teach
and uh and and so i feel like you know
sometimes on these forums
because i care so much about
personal growth and building companies
and being a great athlete that i might
be able to speak to it but like for
those listening don't be fooled like i
fail a ton uh
you know this season has been brutal
alone like it feels like every season is
brutal um and then you know you have
shitty games and you have bad breakups
and
it just all happens it all happens to
all of us
um and so
yeah i uh hopefully there's a couple of
things that some people can take and
um
yeah and i've taken a lot from you and
your show so thanks for watching
oh thanks well i um i i after i you know
started reading more and more and
watching more and more i was like you're
a really interesting dude and i've
appreciated your perspectives on things
because
it's um
it's fun to talk to another athlete
there's so much relatability in the
process and um but it crosses over into
life too and so thanks for your
vulnerability and honesty about how you
feel about stuff and um i just i'm i i
gotta watch a lacrosse game i've never
watched one i'm sorry i i are now now
we've got danica patrick watching the
pll but it's because i've no i know now
your personality and i'm curious about
you yeah
i mean i appreciate that and and i say
that jokingly we
we know where we are that's a huge part
about life is like practically
understanding where you currently stand
that doesn't discount the goals that you
set where you want to be we know that
lacrosse is small i go into every
conversation with someone i've met
knowing that it's more likely than not
that they don't know who the [ __ ] i am
or that pro lacrosse
has never been on their television set
and that's all good i tell uber drivers
to follow the pll on instagram like this
is building one block at a time my okay
this is my last question and so i heard
you say that
lacrosse is an amalgamation of the best
of all sports so sell me sell everyone
go i want to know what this amalgamation
looks like to you well like going back
if you've if you've hung on to listen to
me talk this much which god bless you if
you have um but like i played all of
those sports growing up and so soccer
basketball my brother played football
baseball swimming track and field and
what you get in lacrosse is like the
artisanship of hockey and baseball it's
a stickball sport but you string your
own stick so if you care about your
personality and your style like that's
what lacrosse is it's so artisan
and then the second part is if you love
contact i mean it's a helmet sport which
sucks from a marketing standpoint but
you get to hit the agility of basketball
the endurance of soccer
uh those all of those attributes came
out and i started playing late um i
wasn't until i was in my teens which
today's day and age like you know kids
are deciding their sport when they're
six
no kidding but that's how i felt and
when i
became
really attracted and fell in love with
the games when i learned about its
history which is the native american
sport and stuff that really yeah
something we try to tell now i mean the
game has been around longer than any
sport in the world
it's it's called the creators game it's
the hong ki guajes it was started in the
iroquois
and uh and it it goes back to i mean
talk about when the sport was played
without helmets
um and it's it's a warrior game
and um and it's a sport that we are now
through the pol and our relationships
with the native american community and
some of the top players in the world
still live and places like onondaga and
seneca reservations
um are telling those stories for the
first time where people just thought
lacrosse was you know another version of
polo played in the northeast at
preparatory schools
i feel smarter now
i appreciate you asking that question
yeah and now i'm gonna have to dip into
my slice my tiny little slice of native
american
in me um and do some research yeah i'm
sure we all have some version of it yeah
which is north america
well thank you paul and good luck when
does the season start
well we are started you're in it yeah
we're in it we're in it um but fair
question you haven't seen it yet so
watch this weekend and this will
this will will still be in it i think
when this pocket comes out so
uh we're on nbc nbc sports our
championship games on september 19th so
it's sunday
um on nbc and then all of our games are
available on peacock
and um i'm playing this weekend in
albany
and you have a podcast too i have a
podcast called yep i'll hopefully get
you on it um now as as a favor
um and and maybe i'll ask you what your
what your first uh game experience was
like and tips for our broadcast because
i help oversee those innovations
happy i'm very opinionated so i'm happy
to give you whatever i whatever i
whatever i've got all right sounds good
deal
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today i hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the subscribe button